okay I have a fantastic film
recommendation for you today it is a
film called the sins of my father it is
an extraordinary documentary that tells
the story of Colombian drug lord pablo
escobar through the eyes of his son
sebastian as well as the sons of two of
the victims of pablo escobar i've read
and seen a lot about pablo escobar Louis
I've read the book killing pablo which I
recommend there's a newer Netflix series
called narcos which is uh it's okay I've
recommended it in the past but I've
mentioned that the guy who plays Pablo
Escobar is actually Brazilian so he
speaks Spanish with a very uh
significant accent if you are reading
the English subtitles not really a big
deal so a couple of things in the past i
recommended about Pablo Escobar this
film is extraordinary I mean a hearing
about a guy who ran what is up above an
enterprise of drug running of an
incredible scale I mean it is
unimaginable the scale and a lot of
people don't know the scale of the
Escobar drug world hearing about it from
his son who knew this man as a father it
is absolutely incredible i could not
recommend this documentary more highly
it is on my list i've seen numerous
documentaries about Escobar the whole
thing is is uh really fascinating again
I am talking about the film sins of my
father it is available on netflix and of
course you can get it uh by checking out
david pakman.com slash recommendations
were my full list of recommendations is
if you a stream any of the movies
through the links on that page or by any
of the books through the links on that
page you will be supporting the david
pakman show which is always a great
thing